the corona virus pandemic is making us
go through some difficult times
having little to no social interaction
facing massive losses of life and so
much more
now ironically the most difficult thing
we're facing
is working from home now i say ironic
because working from home was like a
dream to most people
but now that we've experienced it for a
few weeks most of us can agree it's
anything
but a dream on that note i'm raul from
simply learn
and welcome to the session on how to
work from home effectively
today i'm going to give you some work
from home tips that can make the process
a whole lot simpler for you firstly
let's talk about how you can pretend
like you're still at work number one you
need to set up a morning alarm
and wake up as you usually do now one of
the hardest things to do once you start
working from home
is to maintain the schedule that you
used to follow
number two take a shower before getting
started with work
now this step has two advantages one it
seems you up with your normal schedule
and two it freshens you up number three
get dressed like you're going to the
office now this tip is more
psychological
in a way you're tricking your mind into
thinking it's still following the usual
routine
if you think completely dressing up is
too much effort you could also just
dress up your top half
that way you can look presentable in the
mini zoom calls or
hangout beads that you're part of number
four
don't start work immediately now this
one ties back to all the points i
mentioned earlier
without the routine it's possible that
over the span of the day
you could lose interest in work and end
up not being productive
at all number five communicate
expectations with everyone at home
now most of us have families with us at
home
it's really important for them to know
that even though you're at home
you're working from home number six
put your phone in another room or on
silent mode
now this one's self-explanatory i don't
have to explain why this is
really important number seven and this
one's probably the most important
follow your work routine like nothing's
changed so on a normal day if you start
off by checking your email
i would suggest you do the same from
home as well
now let's talk about your workspace
you need to create a workspace for
yourself at home
a place where you can get your work done
without any distractions
number two in this workspace you need to
make sure
only work is done and nothing else
number three you'll also need to avoid
having food in the area
by physically going to another place to
have food
you're subconsciously cementing the
thought that the workplace is for work
only
number four make sure the workspace is
comfortable
this make sure that you're not fed up
with the place after sitting there for
long periods of time as you know all
work and no play
makes jack a dull boy so let's talk
about taking a break
number one make sure you have at least a
10 minute break for yourself every two
hours
now it's very easy to get lost in work
and forget to give yourself some rest
remind yourself to take a break every
now and then to ensure that you are
refreshed
number two spend some time watching
stuff on youtube create songs videos of
kittens or puppies
trailers anything that catches your
fancy
number three spend some time on social
media get in touch with friends through
video call and so on
number four take some time off for food
breakfast or lunch
take a coffee or tea break as well
number five
communicate with some real people at
home it's important that you have some
real interaction with people
during this period of time talk to your
family check in on them
get the conversation going and finally
the end of day you need to log off
and stay logged off now once you're done
try to make sure you switch off from
work for the day
unless there's an emergency that is and
with that we've reached the end of the
session
we hope you guys found this informative
and helpful don't forget to subscribe
sanitize and stay safe thank you for
watching
and stay tuned for more from simply
learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here